how's it going reject nation we are
going to start the witcher finally for
the first time in our lives if you
normally skip intros please stick around
for this one because the uploads for
this are going to be a little bit weird
over the next few weeks ideally we would
like to do this weekly but we know the
season 2 comes out i think december 17th
so there's gonna be some weeks where
we'll probably do two uploads in that
week just to make sure we can be on top
of when season two comes out i was given
this shirt ages ago and i never started
the show but i figured let's start now
that way by the time season two comes
around we'll be done with season one
it's a perfect segue so subscribe click
that notification bell to get notified
when our reactions the next episode of
witcher is up please go ahead hit that
like button that is the number one thing
that helps us out in the algorithm full
length watch alongside witcher over at
our patreon page cover a bunch of shows
over there as well we're at the same
time you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs included i
did put out a post on the community page
about possibly covering this series we
haven't played the games we haven't read
the books but the vast majority of the
comments were saying it's okay to go in
blind to this i hear it's to quote every
eternals review pretty dense
and there's a lot to follow but yeah
just putting that out there right now
we're not familiar with this ip at all
going in blind lastly thank you to prep
for freddie now these highlights i'm
sure it's going to be really easy for
you as we just stood here going what nah
wait wait wait wait wait i don't get it
who's his name what's that guy where are
we right now what's the kingdoms and if
there's any nudity it'll have to be
blurred because it's youtube let's do
this
god what an introduction
not impressed
that's a quote from superman i'm not
saying i'm impressed no
poor dear
you don't give the orders around here
you're a mutant son of a [ __ ]
mutant
i apologize for my man's interference in
your day
hopefully he can improve his behavior by
tomorrow's market sorry van3
it's hard to make a living on main roads
and you desperately need money for new
clothes
maybe you could help them change
[Music]
where are you from carol rivera i don't
know where that is but i could learn
huh
this is probably the best show ever this
is my favorite show
[Laughter]
oh my
just spend the whole show here
i'm grateful destiny brought you to me
you don't want my monster you want me to
kill yours very clever indeed what kind
the voice kind the humankind
its name is renfree
i think our witch is gonna learn to feel
over the course of this show
gonna grow a heart
three times the size of it is now mine
for example is beautiful on the outside
but it is on the inside she has
stretched her bloody talents taught me
wizards are all the same you talk
nonsense while making wise and
meaningful faces
[Laughter]
that's it this applies to many
franchises
and keep that quote in my back pocket
the beautiful one
she's after you
daughter of king freda [ __ ] of cray i
get it okay
i'll pay you anything like your monsters
killing rent-free is
the lesser evil if i have to choose
between one evil and another then i
prefer not to choose it all
you can choose yeah
i would not mess with henry cavill
nope
[Music]
i feel like some shit's about to really
go down in this kingdom right now
i'm about to get red weddings yeah
if we must do this now here is your
first lesson as in life
it is impossible always to be fully
prepared for battle
keep your sword close
and keep moving
that advice is gonna come in handy in
like two
minutes would you honor me with the
dance
uh
martin she'd love to
keep your sword close yeah
i stand corrected
oh time for battle
oh it's the girl what's her name
ravonna rensley
renfrey is the one
[Music]
strogable's man raped me
robbed me and let me go
oh god
you want me to kill dragon ball for you
it's the lesser evil
yes
[Laughter]
people call you a monster too a mutant
what if they come after you
attack you they have
why not
kill them
because then
i am what they say i am
high road for geralt
whoa
hmm
[Music]
oh
wow
my duties to protect you you're
resentful of that burden it's the
greatest honor of my life
the battle's gonna be coming to your
doorstep don't you worry keep that sword
closer
[Applause]
[Music]
i i think we're losing it seems like
we're probably losing
no
he was so likable
that was like a perfect shot damn yeah
yes them
oh i like that guy i know
no supplies
jack we have enough
hi this shit's all going to
yeah she's gonna become a warrior
princess
so he's like they're merlin
kinda yeah
or well
oh
i feel like the other guy in the eden
place was more there merlin this guy's
got power as long as i hold
they should probably close the window
did you do this further inside
[Laughter]
it took two strikes to kill him i turned
to that girl afterwards she was drenched
in the man's blood she took one look at
me screamed vomited
i passed out i thought the world needed
me too the woods of eavesdropping
kingdom of evil
it's our greatest exports
i talk to my horse
that's sad
is it
it's a great way to give exposition
i made my decision
you gave me an ultimatum and i finally
work
tomorrow i'll eat babakin
really i believe this woman
after i've murdered that wizard
two witchers get sexually arrested that
that would be this butcher does
i only have one feeling
lust
is there a back door
we fire arrows at the other side
it's time
you have to go fight all of them
lesson number two
know when it's time to stop
murphy you're conceding health card
takes no prisoners which means that
right now my citizens are being tortured
their insides are being pulled to their
outsides while they watch
their legs lit up fur
their
she's being hyper specific about things
that we don't see happening
they're mostly just getting stabbed
you're making it worse for herman
you are destined for i can't do this
without you we must go your highness
fight girl
[Music]
are they somehow related is she some
kind of witcher
it is time
they've got to lie
are they all just killing themselves
that's i guess my
yeah unless they're gonna hulk out or
something
[Music]
oh god oh that is heartbreaking
no
oh no
poor guy
geez not enough elixir for you
[Music]
the music is so shitty
straight
out of being sarcastic
it's wonderful music
[Music]
yeah horse chase was that the do with
the boner uh
yeah he had like that feather thing
didn't he yeah must be whole life
[Music]
that's definitely the dude with the
boner yeah
it's calling cars
great shots
they're related yeah maybe she has a
witcher she's got the blonde hair
and she's got
i mean her eyes aren't the same color
but she's got unique eyes yeah
you're in the market
covered in blood
you say you can't choose but you had and
you'll never know if you were right you
will try to outrun the girl in the woods
but you cannot she is your destiny
[Music]
she gave us a message to pass on to you
you have to choose the lesser evil it's
an ultimatum
get it
like the dialogue from before
oh my god [ __ ] these people up man
let's do it
let's go
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh whoa damn cool
that's a cool blade
if we cross swords
hmm
peace
[Music]
oh
damn this
amazing choreography
god they put in the work
oh
black canary power yeah
oh
a mutation it influences people that's
how she got these men to follow her she
got to you too didn't she
do not
touch her
you butchered bodies in the streets of
blabikin you're a beast you endanger the
girl
oh no
[Music]
[Applause]
cowards will be with you always
[Music]
she's your destiny
oh [ __ ] man
that was a pilot yeah all right so yeah
we're not gonna talk forever just
because of the fact that all the
episodes are here we're just gonna
you'll see
about our own pace but these will get
released weekly
break it down step by step
that it was a lot to absorb but i feel
like i i've kept up with most of it for
the you know like there are some new
names i've never heard in my entire life
and you got to get adjusted to the
kingdom of course there's like
geography things that we have we don't
yet know exactly
but in terms of like the immediacy of
the situation
i think uh i think the show is shot
incredibly well there's a lot of great
style and flourishes
throughout the way they they use a lot
of their lens i love a good blur
yeah you can really love the glass yeah
you can really feel that in a lot of the
shots the visual effects and the the
scale of the production design feels
just so
rich and enhances the the world building
experience this looks so expensive
yes it does looks like it costs a lot of
money
and
you know granted like it's it's
interesting to not not granted wouldn't
be the right choice of words here it's
interesting to go into this series
and mainly be looking out for henry
cavill as gerald just because of the
fact that it's henry cavill and he looks
so cool
and you know he is the title character
yeah so he's the witcher like going into
here like that's the main thing i'm
looking forward to so when we're cutting
to these other people like the
cirilla folk
the the syndra the cintrions yeah
they're called yeah cereal is the girl
and then watching all that it
you know it's like sometimes i can
it's easy it can be easy with certain
things like the first time i'm watching
dude it could be easy to be caught up in
what details am i really missing about
the bigger world but the job i think
when you're introducing such a major
world and a pilot is getting you
invested in the
immediacy of the situation at hand and i
think that's what this pilot did so well
was like when when the when the person
when they were getting killed in the
battlefield and the queen
is getting killed and like when she's
dying i did find that very heartbreaking
and while i don't fully comprehend
exactly what the war is that's waging
between them yeah and the greater
context and yeah who the other people
are other than they are a nearby rival
kingdom yeah it would appear that this
siri character is
uh has this great power that is a threat
to the lands
but she's not aware of it that's
essentially what i was gathering from it
that's what i mean like the basic
it's important like it's always like a
latch on to the basics at hand and the
emotion i'm set i'm solid and everything
else are just great details to pick up
on
so yeah like getting caught up in that
was really good and and it had really
helped that the acting is also very very
strong
i was a little bit surprised by the
whole uh progression though of gerald
and renfree you know i thought like oh
this is going to be a gerald and renfree
show yeah it's like a team up
actually can i say around is it geralt
or gerald i think it's a hard g i think
it's geralt but i think i got it i could
see it being like gif and jiff though
got it okay maybe maybe there's a debate
you let us know yeah so uh yeah that's
what i thought was going to happen was
gerald and renfrew going to like team up
and he was going to
make that choice but i actually like the
idea of like the con i love i love
things that deal with like the thematic
element of consequences of choices and
actions and
watching how the
presumably i don't want to get too
caught up in theories but presumably
with the
the the the
this character is an apathetic
individual and you watch him slowly
start to feel for certain areas that he
wasn't anticipating and ultimately left
with sort of this pain and guilt
that outweighs the physical pain he has
just endured and now what actions he'll
take
based upon that mm-hmm
right
now what the pilot is supposed to do
sometimes i get a little concerned of
follow this right yeah yeah yeah well
and it's it's funny because yeah at the
outset i was expecting something that's
a little more like smooth jumping in
because yeah like you said it does feel
and the episode is called what the end
of the beginning or whatever and so yeah
it it threw me at first but then i
started to appreciate i think you know
you
there's going to be some element of a
game of thrones comparison with the show
like this and there's one thing that
everyone associates or often you know
touches upon when it comes to game of
thrones is that like oh nobody's safe
and like you know anybody could die at
any point and there's this sense of
real peril just to being in this world
at all and so jumping in here i think
you know i enjoyed this on the level of
knowing that okay there's gonna be fine
details like names geography places
times that i'm gonna have to
you know increasingly familiarize with
as the show goes and even though yeah
i'm
sitting here going okay wait did i catch
everything i feel like the broad strokes
do work and they do make some big
impressions where it's like oh damn i
it's like you said i liked henry thomas
i didn't expect him to die like right
away and and with uh renfree they make
this
very kind of compelling little back and
forth that yeah it takes you by surprise
took us me by surprise and how it
wrapped up and um
it makes me curious about how the rest
of the story is going to progress
because this just isn't the displacement
of any of the people and events that i
had been expecting much like you was
expecting someone so we're definitely
following geralt this whole time and you
know watching as this alliance forms or
whatever and and the only piece of
context i really had coming in to the
show beforehand was that i think they
based a lot of this on uh short stories
that predate the actual like witcher
novels
and through that lens that little piece
of context i can kind of see that
because this did feel like a vignette of
sorts even though it is going to
you know crest into the ultimate i think
overarching plot which is about geralt
and siri finding each other and
you know
creating whatever alliance or you know
thing needs to happen i mean the
impression that i got a striker borer is
a much bigger bad than is being let on
yeah
and i they did a nice
debate of like which one of these guys
should i trust you know well yeah i mean
striker board uses geralt's skills
essentially to manipulate him
um i mean like the manipulation didn't
the vision kind of worked
it wasn't like he made a choice directly
you know like it was kind of a situation
of circumstances in the in the immediate
moment of what was transpiring in the
fight yeah but even right there in that
moment you know just because he wants
the body of renfree right for yeah it's
because he wants the body of rent free
he manages to use his wicked words
that's what i did yeah
words
to
um you know rile up the crowd
yeah and it really show it's like no
matter what motivation you had for the
choice i am the authority here and i can
sway everyone against you and you're
outnumbered now
yeah man i mean it's like
you got a lot of
it's like you don't get a full scope of
the what what i'm
what i'm curious about is how does this
first episode pl is it does it hit
emotionally
harder
if
on a re-watch
yeah not like i watched this episode
that i rewatched the episode but do i
watch the season and then i decided to
go back and watch this i know the
contents yeah that i should be aware of
so that i'm not sitting here trying to
hold on to details and missing the drama
yeah yeah yeah because i'm like some of
the drama
like you're watching a lot of you know
um
devastating effect for a lot of these
characters and and the harrowing nature
of it
that i can't quite criticize
the
emotional intake of it
because a lot of times i'm like
i say mid-season just because of the
the weight and the atrocities that are
occurring and especially in its bleak
atmospheric setting of oh the collapse
of this of this loved kingdom
usually i'm saying mid-season finale or
even finale because that would mean like
though the heartbreaking the intensity
loss but it's hard for me to feel all
that to the to the uh maximum capacity
just because uh i'm like i'm still
trying to understand i'm still i just
got so learning what's going on
absolutely
we're
yeah yeah so what the strength i thought
of what they did with focusing is
letting you get like more acquainted
with geralt and siri
and i think henry cavill does a does a
really good job he's a really good job
and you know you pick up on that he has
uh sure he's like stoic apathetic
however he's
you know he he peppers it in from the
very beginning that there's there's more
going on underneath the surface than
what's led on yeah he's not he's not
just defined by what people perceive of
what you're to be this is some of the
best grunt acting i've seen in a long
time because like
that should be our reaction for all of
episode two
[Music]
nobody's got so many expressive grunts
and i almost wonder if that's a
video game thing or if in the books they
you know kind of point out that he does
that a lot because it seems like a very
specific choice that i i really yeah you
see it in the script
gerald grunts yeah half his dialogue is
just geralt grunts but uh yeah he had
such presence and when the sword fight
came down like it it i'm sure there's
some element of stunt magic happening
there but it really
sold me on them actually having the
fight both uh him and and the actors
playing renfrew i thought that was a
wonderfully staged and really visceral
back and forth yeah and and what i will
give is as much as there is a certain
element of like okay wait you know am i
do i have everything there's a whole lot
happening i was still like oh damn like
i was bummed that he killed her by the
end yeah uh you know and i still felt
for for things like that i wasn't like
heartbroken or shattered not that i
think i
i thought i think i needed to be no ah
but yeah it's like when they were like
starting to build up their sexual
tension and chemistry they sleep
that that was like an actual they slept
together right it wasn't just it appears
that way vision
i'm pretty sure they did that's when i
started getting a little bit confused do
they actually sleep together or was that
just a
dream sequence yeah
they for sure kissed and stuff
so uh yeah i mean i wasn't really
feeling the chemistry but it was it was
a weird thing because i like gerald
and i was overall liking the rem free
character but i wasn't really feeling
their chemistry yeah if that makes sense
i wasn't rooting for them to get
together in any way but i was finding
myself at the end going oh i thought
renfrew was gonna be a character yeah
that's it that's a disagreement yeah
which is i mean which is a good way to
establish that element of like
you know no don't get too attached uh
that keeps a world like this feeling
unpredictable uh but yeah i i guess i
wouldn't have wanted to be prepared for
that but i was taken aback in the moment
i guess i wasn't yes expecting that well
it seems like it's got a really obvious
setup mm-hmm like okay yeah he's not
gonna choose who's gonna care for
renfree and they're gonna go and take on
baddies together and then he's gonna
find out that her motivation probably
was the proper motivation because this
uh strike stroganoff struggle strike a
board guy is uh you know he's
he just shows his hand by the end
because i thought they did at least a
nice job at first i mean when she tells
the context of her story i was pretty
much like you're probably in the right
just because yeah her performance even
just clued that but early on before you
know you get the reveal of you know
strogavor
being very upfront about his intent uh
you know they made a kind of nice little
debate of that
yeah
well i think i think geralt too is he's
initially he
he's an interesting character to me
because you can feel that there's more
i don't know if he like
strongly desires human connection but
there's you can tell there's a part of
him that does he wouldn't talk to his
horse if he didn't have some kind of
yearning for connection yeah exactly
yeah
it's a sign of loneliness
[Music]
that's interesting it's an interesting
character
he's so buff
he is so buff
i think the only thing that that i was
really like wait a minute was was how
did they get the queen from the
battlefield back to the to the castle so
quick
with like no intermittent like that if i
had one gripe at all that's that was my
gripe was sort of like wait wait i just
saw you fall on the battlefield
and this seems like it's a concurrent
moment but you're already back at the
castle what's going on
but i loved her performance i think of
all the performances the queen was my
favorite performance yeah like she had i
agree with you she had
wonderful presents yeah
she felt like really lived in r yeah
yeah i could feel all the character work
she must have done
all that gravity when she's finally
gonna fall out of the window and you
know accept her fate right and even her
backs and forth like i love that whole
thing
where she's talking to siri and and
she's like now is not my time or
whatever and they do that really long
thing where she's like letting go of her
hand just like little intimate moments
like that were some of the richest
character you know actually feeling you
know the resonance of the character
moments for me that's a very good point
very good point
all right guys well
my head hurts it does
i'm not gonna lie i got a bit of
headache
concentration headache
one big ass monster at the top and then
the rest is okay deets and times dates
names places
kind of structure of show are we getting
into
it was uh
i'm gonna take some ibuprofen right now
but i appreciate you guys for being here
and i am looking forward to the rest
i i'm definitely i'm definitely
compelled
leave your thoughts down below
clear up everything
without spoiling spoilers
hit that like button and we'll catch you
guys soon
[Music]
you